vamos a pensar qué sucede con una curva
y ese cuando el gasto gubernamental
cuando g se va hacia arriba para pensar
acerca de eso simplemente vamos a hacer
esto mira vamos a dibujar primero
nuestra cruz keynesiana de modo que en
este eje vertical tenemos el gasto
planeado aquí en el eje horizontal
tenemos el ingreso agregado entonces acá
simplemente son dos formas de hablar
acerca del producto interno bruto verdad
y entonces lo que queremos son todos los
puntos en donde la economía está en
equilibrio donde el ingreso es igual al
gasto por eso es que dibujamos una línea
de pendiente 1 son todos los puntos en
los cuales el ingreso es igual al gasto
y por tanto la economía está pues en un
cierto tipo de equilibrio bueno está en
equilibrio y bueno después de eso lo que
hicimos fue platicar acerca de gastos
planeados de gp y es igual a el gasto
del consumidor agregado que es una
función del ingreso menos los impuestos
o bien que está en función del ingreso
disponible acuérdate que no es una
multiplicación verdad no es sé por yemen
usted sino que se es función de yemen
usted bueno estuvimos platicando mucho
de esta función dijimos que era lineal
que no
porque será así que podría haber modelos
más complicados pero bueno luego tenemos
la inversión planeada más la inversión
planeada y ahorita vamos a suponer que
estamos en una tasa de interés dada o
sea que la tasa de interés está fija por
un ratito vale inversión planeada más
gasto gubernamental más gasto
gubernamental llegan a ponerle también
la exportación neta para suponer que la
economía está abierta ok esta curva de
acá que es el gasto planeado que es otra
vez un repaso nada más podría verse más
o menos así algo de este estilo y aquí
en este punto tenemos un cierto
equilibrio verdad es el nivel de
equilibrio de producto interno bruto
bueno pues también podemos usar esta
información dada esta tasa de interés
real r1 para graficar al menos un punto
uno de los puntos de nuestra curva y ese
entonces déjame graficar uno de estos
puntos espero que ahorita ya te sientas
más o menos cómodo con la forma general
de la curva y ese y ahorita vamos a ver
cómo se desplaza entonces por aquí está
la tasa de interés real y queremos
relacionarla con el producto interno
bruto agregado
entonces acabamos de mostrar en
pasado que si estamos en r1 si este
nivel es digamos r1 entonces si la tasa
de interés real está en r1 entonces el
nivel agregado de producción o de
ingreso está más o menos como esta
altura pues déjame transferirlo a la
otra gráfica entonces nos lleva más o
menos aquí si la tasa de interés sr1
esta es la producción y es el punto de
nuestra curva y ese va bueno ya con este
punto pues más o menos podemos
imaginarnos que la curva y ese se vería
se vería más o menos así estoy acá es la
curva y ese va ahora sí cambiando la
tasa de interés modificando r1 entonces
podemos graficar más y más de estos
puntos sobre la curva y ese y queda con
pendiente negativa como ya lo platicamos
bueno todo esto es pensando en términos
de como un aumento en la tasa de interés
hace que toda esta expresión de acá
disminuya entonces toda la curva se
desplaza hacia abajo y por tanto tenemos
un punto de equilibrio menor si la curva
se va hacia abajo entonces el nivel
queda como por acá verdad así una tasa
de interés alta nos da un menor ingreso
agregado verdad así fue
como pensamos en la curva y ese va ya
que platicamos y repasamos esto pues
vamos a pensar qué sucede si el gasto
gubernamental aumenta pues saber si es
gasto gubernamental aumenta este cachito
aumenta eso lo que hace es desplazar
nuestra curva de gastos planeados hacia
arriba también entonces nuestro gasto en
cambio gubernamental del traje desplaza
esta curva hacia arriba se desplaza la
curva déjame ponerle un poco más bonito
se desplaza la curva hacia arriba y
entonces llegamos a un nuevo nivel de
equilibrio va bueno esa cantidad en la
cual se aumenta el equilibrio este
detalle de hecho va a ser igual al
multiplicador que es 1 entre 1 menos la
propensión marginal al consumo por
nuestro cambio en el gasto gubernamental
ahorita no hay que preocuparnos
demasiado por esto porque pues este
vídeo nada más es un pequeño repaso de
lo que ya vimos pero bueno la razón por
la cual estoy haciendo esto es para lo
siguiente estamos haciendo tú seré uno
no cambio pero al aumentar el gasto
gubernamental logramos desplazar el
producto interno bruto más hacia la
derecha entonces para la tasa de interés
r
desplazamos todo el producto interno
bruto en esta cantidad pero observa eso
va a suceder no importa cual tasa de
interés tengamos así que en general si
aumentamos el gasto gubernamental y
dejamos todo lo demás fijo entonces la
curva y ese se va a desplazar hacia la
derecha en modo similar si disminuimos
el gasto gubernamental la curva se mueve
hacia la izquierda ahora sí ya con esto
en nuestra caja de herramientas podemos
pensar como un cambio en el gasto
gubernamental puede cambiar nuestro
punto de equilibrio en el modelo y sl
vamos a hacer esto deja de dibujar otra
gráfica por acá interés real por acá
tenemos el producto interno bruto o
ingreso agregado como quieras pensarlo y
entonces tenemos algo así la curva y ese
verdad sería algo más o menos como de
este estilo y luego la curva lm que la
voy a poner en rosa mexicano la curva
lm se vería más o menos así bueno
entonces si tenemos un aumento en el
gasto gubernamental vimos que la curva y
ese se desplaza hacia la derecha o
desplácese acá y entonces se vería más o
menos algo de este estilo
ok mira nuestro punto de equilibrio
anterior estaba como por acá verdad como
a esta altura y vimos que cambiando el
gasto gubernamental entonces nuestro
nuevo punto de equilibrio de producto
interno bruto es más alto y también el
nuevo interés es más alto va simplemente
al desplazar la curva y ese hacia la
derecha decimos esos cambios pero me
puedes decir los que no también un gasto
gubernamental pues va a afectar la curva
de lm porque aquí se ve muy fija a lo
mejor un cambio en una política fiscal
pues estamos a la cuarta que fiscal no
es de dinero sino que aumentar el gasto
lo que nuestro afectaría la curva lm
pero pues no porque la curva de lm
depende de como diferentes niveles de
producto interno bruto afectan a la
preferencia por liquidez de las personas
verdad o sea que tanto intereses están
dispuestos a pagar para que les hagan un
préstamo o para prestar su dinero
entonces pues realmente eso no tiene
mucho que ver con el gasto gubernamental
y otra cosa que afecta a la curva lm es
la oferta de dinero verdad si hay más
dinero entonces disminuye su precio y
pensar mejor aquí podría decir que no el
gasto gubernamental aumenta los precios
y lo que sea pero no
y estamos pensando a corto plazo podemos
pensar que los precios son fijos por el
momento y así una política fiscal no
cambia la curva de lm una política
monetaria podría imprimir más dinero o
así o tal vez la preferencia pública es
también la cambiaría pero una política
de gasto pues no no lo cambiaría así en
este modelo bueno estamos haciendo muy
sencillito verdad pero en este modelo si
aumenta el gasto gubernamental la curva
y ese se va hacia la derecha aumenta la
tasa de interés real y aumenta el nivel
de equilibrio del producto interno bruto